elle denis et économiste bonsoir daniel
denis bonsoir vous en pensez quoi
est-ce qu'il faut prolonger la
prestation canadien d'urgence je pense
que les deux vont ensemble prolonger
mais modifie je pense qu'on est à
l'étape du développement de la pandémie
qui est très différent du moment où
cette mesure a été mise en place
on sait l'économie a commencé à les
ouvrir en tant que tel les moins de 40
ans est elle aussi alors il ya des
leçons ou ici à prendre dans le fond des
derniers mois je comprends qu'on était
en mode d'urgence était vraiment
souhaitable de le faire de cette façon
on aura ce moment là mais là je pense
qu'il faut planifier le genre de mesures
qu'on a besoin et on a encore besoin de
quelque chose c'est certain parce que tu
sais pas s'il ya des secteurs
industriels sont encore fortement frappé
mais il faut me grey tranquillement vers
le reste du filet social c'est à dire
sur ses traditionnelles qu'on a comme
l'assurance emploi je dis pas qu'elle
soit c'est presque en mesure demain
matin de prendre en charge mais il faut
que les conditions derrière le titre de
support qui est donnée à la pcu pour les
tout prochains mois s'apparente
davantage à ceux de l'assurance emploi
dont il fit donc à venir quoi ça veut
dire quoi daniel denis ça veut dire
qu'il y aurait une réduction progressive
de la prestation
enfin lyon par exemple d'un revenu de
travail qu'on gagne ou tout à fait dans
certains coins peut-être que les gens
certains égards d'alfort travailler
moins d'heures la paix sud vient quand
même plus falloir parce qu'on avait
effectivement d'une part je pense que
dans la migration
on pourrait atteindre un niveau de
rémunération qu'il faut nécessairement
celui de l'assurance emploi demain dans
les prochains play 3 chez moi mais on
pourrait tenir compte davantage compte
de c'est à dire du revenu qui était
gagné près pandémie pour faire en sorte
que des gens dans le fond qui gagne est
peut-être moins
ce retour à un niveau de rémunération
avec le nouveau programme du s'apparente
officiers qui étaient donnés ou au
niveau de revenu qui avait rien et
surtout je pense
il ya une notion qui est importante la
60 points elle qui est en attente de
apple est éligible dans ce sens oui
faute à la recherche d'emploi mesdames
ou son employeur est un rappel que
rappelle en guinée qui prédit fier on
tolère et la personne est encore
éligible à une libération ces emplois
une des déceptions
que j'ai dans les mesures qui ont été
mis en place et la subvention salariale
voilà lorsque son oncle le prince pcu
devrait migrer tranquillement en termes
de conditions vers celui de l'assurance
emploi pour l'enfant s'intégrer avec le
risque de la protection sociale qui
existe au canada c'est que les
entreprises actuellement oui on peut
dire c'est que des entreprises et aux
individus qui avaient pas droit à la
prestation qui est actuellement en
profiter en a peut-être en tant que tel
qui ont une désincitation travail mais
il ya des entreprises aussi d'une
certaine façon qui est actuellement ça
peut faire leurs affaires dans le fond
d'avoir des employés sont en stand by
s'cusez l'expression anglaise milk sont
en attente
et puis peut-être que leur posture
jamais reviendra jamais peut-être que
leur poids soit abolie en tant que tel
mais pour l'instant dans le fond les
gens en attente de revenir dans leur
emploi antérieur et donc ça marche pas
la subvention salariale mais il ya pas
suffisamment services quant à moi
étonnamment parce que sa mesure qui est
quand même très généreuse la part du
gouvernement et c'est ce qui est comme
si les entreprises vont voir qu'un grand
nombre d'entreprises veulent pas prendre
la responsabilité de vraiment
officialisé lors d'une ampoule hockey et
la lettre sud qu'ils ont actuellement
c'est que leurs employés sont en attente
qu'il cherche pas un nouvel emploi non
plus mais aussi dans tout bon endroit
dans six mois et on peut au besoin d'eux
ces personnes là ont perdu tout ce temps
avant de se qualifier ou de rechercher
un emploi silence auquel il faut inciter
est ce que vous devriez que des
programmes jusqu'à maintenant la voir
fait les programmes maintenant temps de
ralentir la relève
la reprise économique je dirais c'est
pour la main marginale dans le sens
suivant c'est à dire que oui des
employeurs cherchent grosso modo ce trou
et par là même marginale en tant que tel
mais ça pourrait devenir de plus en plus
important est particulièrement pour des
employeurs qui recherchent le profit de
personnes que le moins grand incitatif
avec les mesures actuelles parce que
dans le fond d'incitatifs et plus ou
moins importants dépendant pas du revenu
travailler que les gens gars un prêt
pandémie est-ce qu'il faut absolument
une mise à jour budgétaire très
prochainement ottawa selon vous ouais
bah c'est incontournable
sauf que c'est déplorable certains
égards qu'on mange encore dans le flou
enfin que des attitudes compaq à
certains égards il ya des choses qui
seront pas quelqu'un peut pas
nécessairement déterminer avec précision
ses revenus mais il ya des choix
actuellement qui se font sans
transparence sur les dépenses la
situation budgétaire du droit fédéral je
pense que ça il faut que ce soit fait le
plus rapidement possible bien on vous
laisse répondre au téléphone merci
beaucoup daniel 17 entretien ce soir
ouah au revoir